is the iPad Pro finally Pro well today
I'm gonna push it to its limits with
some unreleased software that was just
given to me we're gonna try some crazy
formats including 8K with the new
DaVinci Resolve 18 which Blackmagic is
doing something the Apple straight up
wouldn't do right at a Gekko this is
wild to see a full desktop UI
professional application with
professional level color grading on the
iPad I'm gonna grab my Thunderbolt
extremely fast SSD let's plug that
sucker in grab this pencil let's hit
import here right there my SSD shows up
I have my Blackmagic projects that were
designed on a Mac now right away we're
getting a lot error but if we go to our
files app there's now DaVinci Resolve
folder I'll select those bam easy three
link these clips here and there we have
it guys the projects I made years ago
opening up perfectly with my color grade
playing back on this iPad smooth has
butter as you guys see we have our cut
page right here now there's no edit page
but they're going to be adding more
features to it we also have our color
page and here I have my notes that are
here this is not going to be an iMovie
version of resolve I can go in here I
could change uh my different grades now
they're also going to be adding Fair
light and fusion in the future the
really cool thing is I can use the apple
pencil for example if I'm making some
adjustments I can make all controls
right here with the Precision of that
device I can use my keyboard with that
mouse or I can just go in and I have
full control of just anything I want to
just by pressing so the speed is really
nice now let's make this a little bit
harder I am extremely curious if we can
open up Blackmagic raw files on an iPad
which is not possible with any other
application look at that right here we
have my 4K denoising project I cannot
believe how quick and snappy all of this
is that relinks way faster than on my
computer I don't know if you guys
understand how crazy this is look at
this I have denoising both temporal and
spatial on raw footage on an iPad let me
hit play now this is really tough most
people don't push it this far we're
running at three four frames per second
for this which is actually very good and
there's gonna be a free version of
resolve for iPad but the paid one is
gonna be 95 bucks not 300 on a computer
so you can pay 95 and get professional
tools such as denoising but then you
look over here we have full camera
settings I can go through and change my
color science update it go through
change the white balance change the iso
of the camera after the fact I have my
full professional color grading tools
here HDR tools curves if you want uh
qualifiers you could do tracking masking
this is the first time that this flow
tool is actually coming in handy look at
this check out all of the effects I
gotta try out some other footage and
look how fast this is okay I have to try
stabilization I'll do this old-fashioned
method
bam we're analyzing and it is done now I
did not time that maybe roughly 30
seconds or so and now we're playing it
back super smooth uh DaVinci Resolve
stabilizer is way better than Final Cuts
and let's take this one step further I'm
gonna M4 some media here bam SSD go
32-bit audio from my professional
recorder here no other iPad app that I
know of can do this now I don't know if
resolve will be able to let's toss this
down here there you go guys recording
the audio you guys see how it's blowing
out there I have a bunch of settings
here equalizer but I'm just going to go
ahead and bring that volume down bam and
now that blown out audio is no longer
blown out now that is powerful that's
what the iPad should have been doing
years ago desktop level professional
applications now I want to try something
else here bam I just logged into black
Blackmagic Cloud where you can
collaborate with up to 10 people I have
my cloud project that is not even on the
SSD and this is some tough footage to be
honest I don't expect this to work it
doesn't on my Mac Pro but check this out
using the hover feature that is actually
very convenient where I can skim through
here and it's showing it let's go ahead
and hit play this is 4K 120 frames per
second 10 bit 422 and it looks like it's
playing back perfectly smoothly let's go
ahead and make it even harder I'm going
to open this up it should not be able to
play this this is 4K 120 in real time
not slow down
120 frames per second you guys can see
right there I saw a couple drop frames
but my Mac Pro is literally one frame
per second and this right here look it
automatically connected with my color
grade here and this is just the first
version that is being released the
hardest kind of codec that is crazy we
gotta bust out the 8K I still can't get
over how fast this is right here all
right guys look at this we have let me
make this little screen 8K we have four
streams of 4K in an 8K timeline which is
AK proraz this is 422 HQ playing back
here look out buttery smooth that is
right there on this iPad that is crazy
to show you guys good inspector here
right there 8192 by 43
320 prores 422 HQ now let me go ahead
and see can we export this AK look at
that this could be one massive file I
don't know if this is gonna fit on the
SSD and look at that we're exporting at
24 frames per second 26 right there an
AK project from AK to AK uh doing the
processing on an iPad and it's rendering
at faster than real time that is very
impressive now you guys let me know if
you want to see how the M2 Chip Stacks
up to the M1 iPad Pro and how much of a
difference we have now that we actually
have software that can support it that
took 50 seconds to export this one
minute AK project with different Luts
applied so it's not just the prores it
is having to process that and that
became a 22 and a half gigabyte file I'm
honestly extremely impressed by how well
the first version works how many effects
and features you have built into it the
performance of it and the fact that
Blackmagic raw works and 32-bit audio
everything else this is what companies
need to be doing this is what Apple
should have done a long time ago and
because of companies like this the iPad
can be more Pro when you can just go and
do everything off of an external SSD
without having to get that crazy storage
copying things over stuff not working
you have Cloud linking that is just
amazing you guys get let me know your
thoughts once again if you guys want to
show down between the M1 and M2 iPad
pros and if that mad performance
difference matters let me know in the
comment section this is Max and I'll see
you in the next video
foreign